i'm smiling
[Music]
oh that felt wrong
[Laughter]
um so smile second episode
of series 10. first uh
jaunt well i would say proper jaunt off
world for built she got to go off planet
a little bit in
uh the pilot but i mean they were being
chased then it's not quite the same as
landing and like feeling like you're
seeing the future of
humanity the ingenuity of what we can
build and then nearly getting
killed by it so this one
this one's it's i'm gonna say it's
interesting but
i've got surprisingly few notes and i
don't know how long
this is gonna end up being it's just
pretty straightforward
the doctor and the companion show up in
a place they would expect to find
people there's no people what happened
how do we stop it from happening again
it's
it it's almost a stock modern era doctor
who
plot yet it's just well
done and it's it's
gonna i feel like i'm gonna have a hard
time
coming up with that many specific points
to say about it
first of all the bots with emoji makes
sense to me especially and i i honestly
actually think it feeds into some of the
nature of what's going on because
ultimately the reason that everything
breaks down is that
no matter how well you program a machine
no matter how much it learns machines
don't have emotions and
you cannot truly accurately
program a machine to understand emotions
like maybe you can program it to see
emotional
signifiers but you know not everyone
weighs their emotions on their sleeves
so that's not always going to get you
the result that you want and ultimately
what causes the entire
problem the reason these things start
killing people is a breakdown in the
understanding of human emotions when
they encounter grief and don't know what
it
is and then draw a very bad conclusion
out of it and the reason
i say that them visually having the
emojis thing
makes sense and feeds into that is
because emojis are about the extent
to which these machines understand
emotion
like they understand sad tear they don't
understand
why they can't properly comprehend
what's going on inside of a person that
causes that
but they can still sum up sad tear and
that very over simplistic
representation visually on their screens
and their faces and on the badges
of what emotions are is very reflective
of the very limited way
that these machines understand what
emotions are it actually
impacts the plot and both bolster
i tried to decide if i was gonna say
boosted or bolstered tried to say both
it didn't work but it it brings the
whole thing up and it kind of
feeds into the to the nature of the
problem
and it became a really easy thing to
make fun of
oh yeah we'll never be rid of emojis no
like if there's there is a reason that
that was decided it's not just because
ooh
emojis let's appeal to the youth so
i i like that i like the design on the
robots
the whole thing the well two two things
i like the notion that the dark works
out which makes a lot of sense that
they started building this place out of
on the foundation of just the ship they
came in
like that's that's your house until you
get something else
built like yeah yeah that makes
total sense absolutely and the idea of
these
of the micro bots or whatever they call
them this time
the doctor who keeps coming up with new
names for
very small and or microscopic uh
machines but anyways it
the idea that the entire building is
made out of them
is a neat idea that being said once you
realize it is pretty much the entire
building
it does it does break the
situation slightly because yeah we see a
chunk of the wall detach and like go
after them but i'm like if it's
literally everything that isn't in the
basement
where the ship is why is only one part
of the wall detaching and chasing after
them why doesn't literally every wall
just just close in around them why only
that one section
so it's a neat idea but it creates a
situation where theoretically
they should be way easy the doctor and
bill should be way
easier to catch for these robots than it
turns out they
are um i'm also
kind of impressed especially given that
they tie
the loss of a parent and deal with the
impact of that on a child
i'm pretty impressed that the deaths
don't get undone
doctor who doesn't always roll back and
undo deaths and actually i would say
it's the minority of times that that
happens
but we have gone from series one
everybody lives being this big momentous
moment heck i devoted entire video to
how awesome
that moment was and how the entire
series up to that point had been
building to it
but we've gone from there to feeling
like
most of the time most people are okay
and we've had enough situations where
people
appear to die and then they don't you
know off the top i had things like
science in the library and the force of
the dead like yes physically they're
dead but their consciousnesses
are preserved and uploaded or you know
things more recently
things like time heist where oh this
thing and it
completely atomizes you oh no it turns
out it's just a teleporter
not to mention you know that they've
been reusing that idea like oh you
disintegrated nope teleport with missy
and whatever and so
while i'm not going to say that doctor
who's been devoid of deaths in the last
few years it hasn't been uncommon
for these things to get rolled back and
i would have expected if they were going
to roll it back
the idea of how damaged
this young boy that we end up seeing his
gun
is going to be because his
mother's dead i think it was established
as his mother but like a parent is
dead i would have kind of expected
that to get undone that to be reversed
in some way but nope
that's uh that's harsh and i respect it
oh talking about the boy though
they did they the episode did a very bad
job establishing
him just one so like bill runs into him
bill takes him to the doctor and he just
wanders off and neither of them notices
like for a while because he's like
wander he's wandering the corridors long
enough to
run into the robots get a badge start to
figure out that something is going wrong
like he has
wandered aways and there and it takes
forever for them to notice that he's not
there anymore
that bugged me a little bit um oh uh we
don't get a ton of nardole in this one
but i'll tell you what you know what
nardole's really good for especially
when talking with the doctor
nardol's a great nag oh
he's so good for that just this this fed
up
thing in his in his voice and the doctor
treating him like a
like an annoying like like an annoying
babysitter
like yeah sure no i'll do what you tell
me too
so i love that dynamic and that's a real
that's just a really good thing to
be slighting matt lucas in for a
recurring part like i and i've
pointed out before nardole gets better
and like this this right here this like
my platonic idea of gnardle i like
nardole a lot but i really enjoy him in
this role as the person who is annoyed
that he has to keep an eye on the doctor
i also really like
how happy bill seems just to
be there just to be on another planet to
be seeing a future i just she has this
wonderful sense of ah
this is just awesome because i've felt
like
with some of the companions not all
but some there's been a sense
of when's it gonna get interesting
when's it gonna get exciting i would get
that occasionally from
rose sometimes i get that from amy
i got that from clara you know it's not
just enough for them to see
other worlds like they need excitement
with it and it's nice to see someone
who's just
amazed bill's just amazed to be there
and i really really like that oh and you
know you know what's something that i
meant
to talk about in the pilot and so i'm
going to bring it up here
i like that the doctor is pulled
towards bill simply because
she exhibits curiosity cause looking at
or at least to my interpretation the
reason the doctor has
taken on some of the companions it's
been a bit of a mix
because honestly with both amy and with
rose
it felt a little bit like well that's
the first person that he ran into
he just kind of built an attachment and
then you know with someone like clara
there's that draw of the impossible girl
and all of that you know with but then
there's someone
and even with donna like he was thrust
into a situation with her
and you know came to appreciate who she
was but
like he she wouldn't have caught his eye
otherwise
it was really only martha was pretty
much the only other one aside from bill
where the doctor went oh
you yeah yeah so it's nice to see that
back rather than
it feeling either like the doctor is put
in with the companion by
forced by circumstance or because he's
solving a mystery
so i like that about how
the setup of how bill and the doctor
came together and i feel like that's
continuing to play out
in things like how excited she is to be
on another planet
and continue to make these
again slight just slightly off-center
observations that are valid but not
the sort of thing that shows like this
would normally ever bring up so i
i that's continuing to be a part of her
character so i love that
oh i also like that there was a nod from
the doctor to the fact that
the whole ship's fleeing earth thing
that he's run into a few
over the years i that's that's the kind
of
continuity line i love because without
diving into a ton of detail without
blogging or even slowing the scene down
it just establishes yeah we know this
kind of thing has happened elsewhere
before it's an acknowledgement of the
continuity without
getting dragged down by the continuity
because
anyone who has been watching the show
for a while would know
like wait like they fled a a dying earth
didn't we see that in like back in
classic with things like ark and space
and like we know the earth eventually
became uninhabited because we saw it
in the end of the world and like then we
had
beast below with starship uk like wait
so
just just a little line going yeah i've
run into a few of these over the years
just simple and just it just ties stuff
up and it's just a recognition of yeah
no no
we know that we've done
this premise of why humans are on
another planet before
we'll probably do it again just roll
with it and i like that
i think that's about all i've got the
few
issues i have are pretty nitpicky like
like the kid
wandering off just like oh
i i like the acknowledgement of the
doctor
that the robots have basically become a
new species
it it feels like a natural progression
kind of from what went on with the
gangers in
uh the rebel flesh and the almost people
uh these these things that humanity
created have
clearly come to some level of
consciousness but there it was less
of a leap because they still looked or
at least were capable of looking
like people whereas the robots
definitely
don't but that doesn't mean they have
any less right to be
treated as a species and
negotiated with and
and respected for their own
personages uh and so i i do like that
i kind of wish that that had had more of
a through line
it does seem a little bit thrown in
towards the end
but it does tie in a little bit because
as i said
you know these machines don't properly
understand human emotions
but there's more to life and existence
than that that is not all that defines
sentience human beings especially in
sci-fi settings
there tends to be this putting on a
pedestal the idea of our
emotions yeah i mean all the way back to
you know star trek and
how often it was
something that was framed with spock and
how logically was as
not a failing but something that's like
set him apart and made him less human
and or again sticking with star trek
someone like data where
the thing that he eventually adopts to
try and feel more human is an emotion
chip
there's a lot of pinning of this idea of
well if it
feels the way that we understand
feelings then maybe it's really life
and i kind of like this uh and again it
doesn't dive into it that deeply but i
i do like this acknowledgement that like
there is more to life than
feelings and these this can be a valid
form of life
as well and the fact that they don't
have
and understand emotions is again kind of
at the root of the problem so i do
like that but it is just kind of i i've
got to connect those dots and the
episode doesn't do a lot
with it it's just kind of there i do
like it but i i wish
that if they were going to go there it
had been a little bit more central a
little bit more integrated but
it's fine that that aspect is fine and
the episode as a whole is pretty good
it's
better than i remember um not that it's
amazing but it definitely
does not have very many stumbling points
and lots of what's going on like i like
it's good i dig it smile you re-watched
it lately what'd you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it usual stuff
like share subscribe all that things i
have a patreon
which is how i pay the bills and keeps
this entire thing
up and running any help is greatly
appreciated and there are of course
perks
and all that but no pressure you don't
have to
end of the day you are the council i'm
only running the meetings
and until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you um
[Music]